Learner B3: أم.
Learner B1: الله الله.
Learner B3: أنوي الشباب إلى غوار.
Learner B1: الحمد لله.
Learner B3: مدلع.
Learner B1: يا رب.
Learner B3: الدنيا ملئة.
Learner B1: شغال في الطق و.
Learner B3: نايف ويعتبر ده آخر ستاند أب تقريبا لينا.
Learner B1: بالضبط.
Learner B3: بكرا بقى مش عارفة حنخش ولا هيبقى مشغول.
Learner B1: أم أوكي.
Learner B1: يبين شوية 5 5 دقائق كمان يعني أعملهم منشن ومين اللي ناقص.
Learner B3: ونادا.
Learner B1: ماذا؟
Learner B3: مش عارفة.
Learner B1: هذا و فرنش.
Learner B3: زينب دخلت زي كده زينب.
Learner B1: الحمد لله على السلامة يا زينب يعني أنا مش فاتحة معدن السطح ولا كانت الفتحة من قريب
Learner B1: جن جن تان في إمم إمم.
Learner B3: أم.
Learner B1: هل ده معاه حاجة في التاسكت.
Learner B3: قد
Learner B1: واقف مع حاجة في الط يعني ولا شغال فيها ولا الدنيا تمام ولا
Learner B3: أنا بصراحة يعني مركزة أكثر في بس عايزة لما الكاس.
Learner B1: بكرا.
Learner B3: ، ما عارفة.
Learner B1: أم.
Learner B3: متى كنت بدأت فيها يعني.
Learner B1: إيه.
Learner B3: كنت بدأت فيها
Learner B1: أنا جاتلي رسالة من أحمد منصور إن التذكرة قفلت.
Learner B1: أن.
Learner B1: ما شاء الله ما شاء الله.
Learner B3: وقت أصلا. بيجي مسج إن هو إكستند كمان للسبت ومش عارفة فبصراحة يعني حاسة مركزة على
Learner B3: بروجكت يعني عامة.
Learner B1: الخير.
Learner B5: هو حد يعرف أدي موديل هيبقى إمتى.
Learner B3: بصي هو أنا كنت سألت وكان قلي تقريبا أو كنت تقريبا على يوم ثلتعشر
Learner B3: اللي هي سارة. أنا ما أعرفش بقى بس ما إحتمالية يتأجل بس مش عارفة.
Learner B5: يعني أسبوع أو أسبوع ونص كده.
Learner B3: ممكن يعني ممكن يبقى الخميس الجاي لو بكرة ل 4 جيه.
Learner B5: تمام.
Learner B3: إنتو أصلنا لكم يبقى أحسن أون لاين ولا أوف لاين.
Learner B5: لا أونلاين الحية.
Learner B3: أوكي وإنت أصلا يا روان من القاهرة.
Learner B5: لا.
Learner B3: أوكي.
Learner B5: أنا من البحيرة.
Learner B3: يعني حيبقى بعيد أوي فعلا.
Learner B3: وزينب تقريبا برضه مش من.
Learner B7: منها بس قريبة منها.
Learner B3: هو إنت فين.
Learner B7: الرواية.
Learner B3: بجد قريبة أد
Learner B7: جاي مثلا من القاهرة. أنت من جيزا صح.
Learner B7: هم التلاتة دول كدا بيبقوا التلاتة قرايبين من بعض.
Learner B3: أم أوكي
Learner B3: بس بالنسبالك يبقى أونلاين عامة أحسن أنت أصلا قررتي تحضري.
Learner B7: هو ده أوبشن.
Learner B3: إنت ما عرفش بتقولينا مش حابة بس إحنا يعني تعملي إيه.
Learner B7: لأن وقتها الدنيا ما كانتش واضحة. خالص دلوقتي بقيت حاسة هم عايزين تحسين بشكل واضح
Learner B7: والتذكرة دي تحسها حاجة بقت يعني
Learner B7: زي حايل كده أوتوماتيك بتتعمل بس مش أكتر
Learner B7: بقيت حاسة حاجة سورية بالنسبة لي يعني.
Learner B3: أم أم
Learner B3: بس يعني بشكل عام طالما انتي حاسة إن إنتي مستفيدة أي كان من أين يعني حاسة دي أهم حاجة.
Learner B7: لما اشتغل على حتة تحسين يعني دلوقتي يعتبر أصلا سبينت ون وتو وثري كمان وفور كلهم في حتة وحدة
Learner B7: على التوسك الأخير ده.
Learner B3: بس.
Learner B7: أحس أنا استفدت بقى.
Learner B3: أوكي بس حاسة إن هو إنت يعني إحنا حنستكشف ده أكثر لو خلاص حنشتغل في الفيلد يعني أكيد في الشغل هنستخدم حنستخدم اللي إحنا أخذناها يعني
Learner B3: بالذات ما فتحت يوتيوب لقيت لا في كل فيديوس كتيرة فا
Learner B3: الجسم دي حاجة تستخدم يعني لايف عادي.
Learner B7: من أني كونسبت بالضبط.
Learner B3: بتاعت الكرايمونت
Learner B3: هي بس الفكرة دي موديه إحنا حنعرض مش حنعرض هو ده ممكن يبقى السؤال بس إنت في كل تعمليه يعني رايح ناحية الحتة دي.
Learner B7: هي بس عشان مصطلحات وحدة كاكا هو نفس المجال فالمصطلحات واحدة المطلوب 1 بروسيس نفسها واحدة
Learner B7: فده اللي ممكن تحسيه لكن
Learner B7: دلوقتي مثلا بماينسات معينة ده مش حيتحقق لما كون فأنا اشتغلت على بروجكت على ده.
Learner B3: أم شهر يعني كده كده لما نشتغل حيبقى الموضوع أوسع يعني بس
Learner B3: إنت يعني حضرتك مش مستفيدة أوي.
Learner B7: لا مستفيدة عادي يعني أخدت إكسبور على المجال بشكل أوضح شوية خصوصا إن أنا يعني من الغلط.
Learner B3: إنت أصلا هتكملي في يعني هتكملي برودك مانجمنت ولا.
Learner B7: ده اللي بفكر فيه دلوقتي بس الفكرة إن لما بلاحظ الناس دخلوا إزاي ما بيبقوش لسه فريش بيدخلوه من حاجة أصغر جوا ال تيم الكامل بتاع اللي بيحتاجوا اللي بيحتاجوا في شغله بيدخلوا كحد حد مسؤول عن حاجة جوا ال تيم ده
Learner B7: وبعد كده يكمل بقى كورسات تانية أو ديبلومة أو أي حاجة ويتجه لنوع يكون برودك مانجر فاهمة لكن مبقاش لسه متخرجة واسمي برودكت مانجر حتى لو كنت
Learner B3: حابة تشتغل يعني شغلانة معينة ومع الوقت يعني قصدك انت شفتي يعني.
Learner B7: لأ أنا حابة ال برودك مانجمنت عادي بس الفكرة قواكع مش بتخرجي في التايتل ده
Learner B7: بتتخرجي الاول في طاولة الأصغر
Learner B7: من ضمن ال تيم اللي بيحتاجو عامة بعد كده سنة اكتشفتي وجوا الشركة دي حاجة أنا لاحظتها من ناس كتير مثلا قالوا كده لما تتخرجي اسمك برودكت مانجر فدي حاجة مش بتكون موجودة.
Learner B3: لا، هو أصلا تقريبا في الأول برودكت أون حاجة كده.
Learner B7: لأ لأ.
Learner B1: بص هو الفكرة في كذا مسمى وفي كذا حاجة يمكن على حسب يعني مثلا لو في أكاونت مانجم
Learner B1: لو في مثلا ممكن يكون اسمك
Learner B1: لما اللسكوب بتاعك بيكبر شوية يبقى بروتكت أونر وبتاخدي حاجات
Learner B1: على حسب الشركة الكبيرة مثلا يعني بقى في مثلا و و
Learner B1: وحاجات لو شركة طيران انت ممكن تقومي بكل الليلة دي يعني وسكوم ماستر
Learner B1: على حسب انت ممكن لو لو عايزة تتخصصي في في حتة. إنك تجيب برودكت ودوري عن مشكلة و
Learner B1: وتلاقي حل ليها وتتكلميها مع خلي في مخك يكون هو إيه دي حاجات إسمها طبعا بودكت يعني أي كان
Learner B1: كبساطة كبداية ليها إنت بتبدئي مثلا لو في سوفتوير ده اللي إحنا فيه ده يبدا.
Learner B7: هو فعلا بتبقى أسهل حاجة للناس الفرش.
Learner B1: بس وانت فكري كده كفكرة الحتة دي هتروح قدام فين بس كشغل يعني كشغل اللي حتسلميه
Learner B1: لا سلمني شغل دي هتعملي فيغما
Learner B1: كده يعني بس لأ عادي ممكن تخشي بيها من دلوقتي بس يعني إن ربنا يوفقك كويسة يعني
Learner B1: خدي كورسات واقري يعني هو دي أكتر حاجة بسمع عنها يعني.
Learner B7: تمام
Learner B7: هو فعلا معتمدة فعلا حجم الشركة
Learner B7: وفي كل المجالات يعني مش المجال ده بس.
Learner B3: عامة. يا جنب هو ده أكيد برضه ذكي إينسايت مثلا حبة بعد كده تمشي في أي إتجاه أكتر فاهمة
Learner B3: غود لوك يعني
Learner B3: طب هي نادر ردت عليك.
Learner B1: فيش أي حد فاتح ياسر فاتح وسمو.
Learner B1: بقول ياسر فاتح عثمان خلش.
Learner B1: وندى مش فاتحة.
Learner B3: هو ياسر مكتوب 25 دقيقة من 25 دقيقة.
Learner B1: جبن السمكي.
Learner B3: من 25 دقيقة ياسر.
Learner B7: أظن يعني أصلا ما إشتغلناش عالتوست
Learner B7: أنا ما فيش حاجة أتكلم فيها رنجة.
Learner B1: بصي هو آخر يوم تسليم
Learner B1: يعني لو حاجة وقفت معاكي وأنا بحاول أخلصها دلوقتي معاكي كلمني الحوت.
Learner B3: أنا عندي سؤال معلش بتعتك.
Learner B1: أنا أولي معاكي.
Learner B3: هو في يعني في و برودك مانجمنت وبيزنس مش فاكرة بيزنس هو دستور ماركتينغ تاني فستق.
Learner B1: ده أنت تقصدي.
Learner B3: الدنجيبس الموجودة.
Learner B1: كان.
Learner B1: كنت كاتبهم في الفرن.
Learner B1: أنا و برودكت مانجر وفولستيك وبيزنس.
Learner B3: حاسة في حاجة ناقصة سلطة ماركتينغ.
Learner B1: إيه.
Learner B3: في تقريبا كويس ماركتينغ سوري تشاك
Learner B3: مش عارفة بقى كونترايشن ولا كونتينت ماركتينغ ولا.
Learner B1: ما أعرفش أنا لما عملت المسارات دي
Learner B1: لحظة أعمل حاجة راقي.
Learner B3: ينسي
Learner B3: لديك ندى الغبور
Learner B3: تبقى مع حد موجود
Learner B3: إنت مايك عندك في مشكلة يا ندى؟
Learner B3: في
Learner B3: أم خلاص أوكي طب إنت عاملة الدنيا معاكي إيه مش متأكدة بس شكله كده آخر ستاند أب لنا
Learner B3: لو حيبقى فعلا بكرا آخر أسبوع يعني
Learner B3: أنا الحمد الله تمام بدأت في التاس كورد
Learner B3: بس اليمين دول بعمل يوزر انترفيوز يعني وكده
Learner B3: تسلمي بدك لكن كمان
Learner B3: لقيت إينسايد مختلفة حسن، أنا بحاول أعمل يعني كذا مختلف
Learner B1: نتجت الحمد لله.
Learner B3: ، هي بتكلم بس علشات
Learner B3: إينسايس مختلفة. بصي؟ يعني ممكن لما بعمل جوبس مختلفة ممكن يبقى في مختلفة وجربت أعمل مع منتور أصلا أنا حابة آخذ إينسايد تاعت نفسهم شايفين ازاي فبصراحة سهم هيدفل يعني وبدون إينسايد حلو
Learner B3: أنت وإنتو عامة يعني
Learner B3: طيب جماعة لو يعني ل 6 دي
Learner B3: إنت إيه بكرة مين الممنتي أنا كنت سألت من كانت مش فاكرة اسمها بس كان في جروب البزنس
Learner B3: بس يعني الفكرة بشكل عام إن أنا عايزة أعمل مع يعني
Learner B3: إنت فيسبوك. لا قلت لك وبصراحة أنا لقيت ناس حلفة أوي يعني
Learner B3: فلو هتعملي ميتينغ مثلا غوغل ميت أو زوم أو حاجة يبقى موضوع لذيذ
Learner B3: تسلمي والله يعني إن شاء الله كلنا نعمل شغل حلو
Learner B3: هو عامة. كان بعت إسم المانتر بتاع الدجتل سوري بتاع البزنس يعني في الجروب،
Learner B3: سيدي أنا كنت عملت معاها بس يعني
Learner B3: كنت ألريدي تواصلت معانا من قبل ما ما يبعد
Learner B3: لو جماعة وفي حد تاني حابب يعني يشارك حاجة يعني ساكتين النهارده كله تمام.
Learner B1: تمام بس بعمل مع الأخير يعني.
Learner B3: والله غود لك يعني هو ده بس آخر حاسة آخر ستاند أب لينا حساء يعني كله تمام
Learner B3: نعم، طيب يعني لو حد مشال حاجة أو
Learner B3: كله هيبقى مشغول في تمام كده
Learner B3: أتفق بكرا بكرا. أه مش عارفة أنا مع منزل ولا لأ
Learner B3: بس يعني على خير إن شاء الله
Learner B3: والده اصلا مش عارفينها أونلاين ولا حنروح يعني لسه
Learner B3: يعني نسمع منهم خبر كده بس يعني لو مش هيبقى أونلاين فنقابلكم بقى إن شاء الله
Learner B3: إن شاء الله يا ندى خلاص هي ما في أي حاجة يعني نحنا مع بعض وأنجوي
Learner B3: طيب أوكي يلا باي باي.